[Applause]
yo
man a boo lakehead podcast with
special guests whose new project 1984 is
uh officially out everywhere
the homie gashi yo what's up thank you
for having me
um let's talk about the 80s bro i just
want to start off because i've been
listening to your project
and it is truly nostalgic
yes in every capacity yeah i saw you
riding around in the old school bends
yeah and the delorean delorean i got the
bands i got the
uh the royce the rolls royce 1984.
what year were you born in i was born in
uh i'm a 90s baby
okay yeah because i was born in 87 so i
don't even remember the 80s
yeah so what um why the 80s
um basically i
i'm in love i love movies
you know i love movies and i have my
favorite movies you know and
one thing that i found myself um
so so i stopped doing drugs for a while
okay and i'm proud of myself
i don't for a while does that mean
you're like doing them again now
no it means for a long time i haven't
done them okay
and congratulations thank you so much
and
i feel like i found
what i found my drug and
it was john hughes movies oh wow
pretty in pink yes that's a joke yeah i
think so
um just like those 80s movies like the
yeah breakfast breakfast club was fine
yeah all the just
just like all those movies even home
alone you know like all those movies you
know
and um they make me feel
like when i was an immigrant in a
different country
because i'm not from america right so
when i was in a different country i
would watch the tv as a kid and be like
yeah i wish
i lived in a house i wish i had all
these
uh family members running around i wish
i had like a kitchen a refrigerator
and a microwave and my own room and
stuff like that and that
that was like my dream to have that like
that was always my dream
and um i
watch sorry about that i watch and
listen
i watch and listen um
to 80s music to feel like a kid
and uh that's my drug so i eat a lot of
food
i have a lot of random sex okay so
random sex food
and 80s movies with 80s music and that's
what got me to 1984 and i did 1984
2015. i just never put it out so this is
a
five-year-old album and now uh
it's funny because the 80s have such a
like distinct
sound and i would almost argue that like
the popular consensus might be that 80s
music might
maybe has aged worse than most other
decades of music
yeah wouldn't you say like i don't know
but but it's just
i think it's dope because obviously it
was a very um
brave and
you like like you did a whole album yeah
you know what i'm saying
you really committed bro yeah i mean you
know i
2020 is the new 1984. and um
i'm glad i put it out now i remember you
telling me
the story about how you heard rosenberg
play your song
yeah like it's almost like at the
tipping point of whether or not you're
gonna keep going
a hundred percent man i was gonna drop
out you were gonna you were taking the
trash out or something right yeah no i
was gonna drop out i was gonna um
no well not dropping i was gonna quit
music and go back to college
and then you heard it on real eight yeah
so my mom had a
my mom had the thing uh my mom had a
night shift and i was driving her sunday
night shift
at 12 o'clock and while driving her the
song came on on the radio and it was
like a sign
and it was just like at the house your
mom was in the car yeah she was gonna
come with me oh that's gotta be crazy
yeah and then the feeling of it was so
amazing that i was like yo
i love the feeling so much i was like yo
this is like you know the younger me is
so
nuts like i was crazy like
i was so crazy you understand like the
way i was
thinking then i i laughed i really
laughed like
yo i feel the same way sometimes you
think back to just the [ __ ] that you
were like
that you the way you would act or the
thoughts that used to go through your
head when you were like
1920 but like damn well who the [ __ ] was
i back then
exactly it's so embarrassing you know it
is so [ __ ] crazy
i literally thought that i was going to
be like the biggest [ __ ] rapper in
the world
at one point i mean [ __ ] man
keep chipping away dawg nah i'm done no
i i mean
artist rapper i am going to be the
biggest artist yeah that's a different
story
but i thought i was going to become a
rapper yo man you guys got it you got to
get rca in line over there
i thought they dropped the ball in that
my year record something crazy bro
yeah i thought that [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
slam dunk i was like oh my god
there's this is the one that's gonna
push him over yeah like how does rc
[ __ ] this one up i think it's like a
perfect example of
there's certain times when like labels
just don't know how to work certain
artists
yeah and i feel like they don't know how
to work you
and it's like it's i'm kind of glad they
didn't
that's fair because then you would have
been in that box yeah you had been into
my yearbook yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] like it's been two years since my
year
that's crazy right yeah it has been it's
been almost two years yeah yeah it's
been two years since my year
but i get booked 150 100 to 150
000 for one night one one new year's
night
to perform that song solomon helps you
with that outfit yeah so that's mike i
saw him
that's my that's my brother i've known
like 15 years that's my guy
so we get paid like the biggest bags on
new year's to perform that song
so i have a song even though i'm like
like a singer now artist now pop artist
i still get booked to perform that one
record so i'm like i'm like mariah carey
on christmas
or new year's christmas because mariah
carey
what was the name of that one chick uh
that had the graduation record what was
that bitch's dick
yeah what graduation fast pico yeah we
remember
that's like that's like the graduation
song and that's like her only record
but it's like you know but you still
play it everybody there forever
it's like a song that'll be there
forever that my years exactly so my year
started a year after it came out started
the baseball
champ started the baseball season
ended the baseball season at the
championship started the basketball
season
ended the basketball season championship
so no matter what you say
it's gonna be my year it's gonna be my
year forever so i will forever
have that song put money in my pockets
and my family pocket it's beautiful man
yeah but going back to what i was saying
i was you know
i i fell in love
with feeling like a kid again and
[Music]
i made this album 2015
and i made it for myself i didn't want
to share it with the world it was kind
of like my xanax
it was like hey let me throw this on and
just vibe every time i would go through
my problems
i would play the record i'd be in my
house i'd turn on an 80s movie
i'd make like a nutella sandwich and
feel like a kid
with no problems and that would get me
through
life cove it happened
everyone hit rock bottom i felt it was
right
to put this out and it's been the
greatest
responses i've ever had in my entire
career for any project
any song that i've ever released and
i've released a lot of songs that have
gotten me a lot of
single god for a couple of years yes
they've gotten me a lot of love you know
but
i've went platinum you know on records
i've
went triple platinum my records i've
i've done so much
and i'm still treated like an
underground artist which i
love and adore because i don't want to
be
the the number one artist and everybody
forgets about no no one cares about
because you know
the number one artists are not cool and
the the artists that are number one are
not played at the parties i attend
so and that's something that i learned
from a guy named black coffee
shout out to black coffee yeah shout out
to black coffee he taught me that and i
had to
store that in my head you know and
1984 was not made for mainstream
i mean listen i feel like when i heard
it i was like this
is uh this is like one of those projects
that's like
it's not like you said it didn't feel
like it was made
for radio it just felt like hey
it's a concept i remember when i was a
kid prince paul put out a a
a album that was uh it was like a movie
on
on i think it was called like the prince
of thieves or some [ __ ] but it was like
50 songs and it was like a movie it was
like yo this is like
dope it's just a creative like it's just
first of all
your creator first you're artist first
and i think that's true artistry you're
not making it for
you know the accolades as much as it's
like yo why not do a concept album in
2020 because nobody does that [ __ ] no
more
yeah the idea of a concept album has
like gone away with
spotify and playlists and all that [ __ ]
yeah i mean kids are making
music for playlists and i'm not and i
feel like
i feel like you know some of the
greatest people
have hit me up after this album i mean
you have sting
on a song i know and now i'm not even
gonna lie to you
i'm not the biggest 80s music guy
obviously the police legendary sting
legendary
i mean as a kid my only sting memory was
when he came out and performed missing
you
with a puff daddy at the uh vmas but
like
dog sting is one of them guys he's one
of the jedis
yeah and he think and he feels that way
about me now so
how did that relationship feature happen
because no one's getting sting on
projects like
i know my manager played the song
for uh his manager and his manager
played my album for him
and uh he picked mama as the biggest
song
of 2020 and he's like i would love to be
a part of that so he wrote his verse cut
it send it back to me and then wrote me
and um
i just think like he did his research
you know he saw that um the new york
times
like called me like the trap phil
collins because i do like
sing like phil collins kind of sometimes
on track beats but like
um he respected everything my grind he
heard my story
and uh cut it send it back i love that
and we
just kept in touch and i haven't had a
chance to meet him because of
what's going on yeah because he's in
london but um
this has been the best response i've
ever had with any song any music
nothing but blue checks in my dms of
like legendary artists writing me saying
how much they love and appreciate the
album and how much they love my song
lies and they love my song mama so much
and
you know kanye west probably you know
people heard kanye west loves don't kill
me
and mama and stuff like that and like
from like people that have like similar
people we have
mutual friends and stuff and like like
just like legendary people listen
listening to my project and and then
writing me and
it just feels like such a blessing
because i released it for me
in case i did die because 2020 is like
killing everyone
you never know so in case i did leave
earth i just wanted to
put out a project without um someone
putting it out for me and adding a bunch
of features
that's fair yeah um
so you so you said that you essentially
had kind of replaced
um i'm assuming was it did you would you
consider yourself someone who had a drug
problem
no no recreation i had a mental
problem okay i think mentally
i'm [ __ ] i was [ __ ] mentally i
wanted to
mentally i was off and i um was so sad i
was depressed
and i was
kind of i was like a bit suicidal you
know what how long ago was this
2013. okay i was just so down
it was just like like just the thought
of it is scary you know
i didn't want to leave my room like no
one could get me out of my bed
like i was just so [ __ ] up i was done
and you know
like if it wasn't for my mother i don't
think i'd be here because you know my
mom prays for me and stuff like that
like
i know it sounds a bit stupid but like
prayers really work
like you know people that are like
people that are connected to the
universe it don't really matter about
like what religion you are it depends on
like how connected you are
to the universe and i think my mom's
found a way to get like when her mother
died she found a way to get connected
with the universe to like keep her
stable and
like she's tapped in she's tapped in
yeah so she prays for me and stuff and
i think it works and i'm i'm a bit
worried
because i don't think i'm going to be as
strong when i don't have my mom by my
side
in a few years so i think that we're all
worried about that when that day comes
right when we lose our parents like i
still got both of my parents but like
oh [ __ ] just the thought of like my
grandma just died this year because of
coverage
she was crazy she was in a nursing home
and uh
that was one of them ones where it was
like man
you know she was like 92 so it was like
okay
you know kind of still prepping myself
for a while but my parents i can't even
imagine let's not talk about it
yeah it's crazy man um yeah it's you
know what i always appreciated about you
yashy was your energy man like
not only be like before i met you and
interviewed you
i felt like your energy was very like in
everything you do whether it's your
social media or your music
it's very prevalent that like your
energy is fire like and i remember when
i first met you
and uh we interviewed you in like 2017 i
think yeah
um i just remember saying like man this
dude is like
i just want to see you win you know what
i'm saying appreciate it and uh
you know seem like a really authentic
guy
now since then i remember that i think
that might have been when you
first first did the roc nation situation
yeah probably yeah
um and you you had some some spotify
success
yeah shout out to my tumor really helped
me out shout out to tumor man he's at
youtube music now
to him ever since he left wrap caviar is
really not relevant yeah we
we we had the wrap the wrap caviar
conversation off the mic but yeah but
i'm curious like since i first met you
to now obviously you've had a lot of
success
commercially um you've been through
different situations yeah um
have i always notice like it's almost
hard to get through this industry with a
certain amount of success without it
kind of like
tainting you a little bit do you do you
feel like you went through that at all
or has
like like has running through the
industry gauntlet
the last few years like affected you in
a negative or positive way because
i i feel like it definitely can i mean
i think um i think um
i'm i'm over it i'm not i'm over
i'm over it um um i think that's why i
made the 1984 album because the magic
was gone
i'm it's all a lie
it's all fake it's not real meaning
everything okay everything's not real
your favorite artist right now the
biggest pop star in the world has a
hundred million followers and
ninety
like i wish the normal human brain like
i wish
that normal human being would wake up
and just see how stupid this is like
the likes are fake the comments are fake
everything's fake like everything's fake
so they look at me and they say things
like damn gushy
he only has 23 million um only he has 23
million
views on youtube where he only has 200
000 the first week damn
like those are real people like those
are legit
real people we understand like you know
these people buying 500 million
streams on spotify frank frank sinatra
is not even getting that
after a joker movie comes out and the
theme song is that song
usually the songs go up those numbers
are not even flying you understand
what i'm trying to explain to you i'm
trying to explain to you is like there's
a curtain that
that can be pulled back with this music
[ __ ] man and i've started to see it a
lot man
yeah it's just so bad
i live in a scary time that's all i'm
saying i live in a scary time
movies are not the same not the same
everything's so microwaved the kids are
brainwashed
they have enough they don't know they
like things because it's cool to like it
such it's such a terrible time
for music movies and everything and
probably the most judgmental time too
we've ever been like
yeah like you can't even make a mistake
anymore no you get canceled you know
it's like they want like like people are
just waiting for for you to [ __ ]
see something they don't i'm kind of
waiting for me to get canceled
because just to get it over with just to
get it over with you know what i'm
saying it's like having coveted
you know that's some real [ __ ] bro like
just get it out the way
because you know like like you and i are
like when we grew up like
i'll be listening to some old m m [ __ ]
sometimes and i'm like
[ __ ] man i was like
how are they not picketing in front of
his house in detroit right now that's
what i'm saying
i don't want to bring that up i don't
want to bring that up because i just but
it's but it's
[ __ ] crazy it is crazy i'm not going
to bring that up because i don't want to
give any of these
wrestling ideas you know what i'm saying
yeah
i don't want to bring that up because
like honestly marshall mather's lp
changed my life
bro he has a whole entire song about
murdering his mother
bro murdering his girlfriend kim is one
of my favorite
see like and raping his mom for the
record yo
kim is you know when he kills he murders
his girlfriend
and on the album it's one of the most
insane things i've ever heard in my life
and i wish i had
i wish i had a video that's one thing
that i wish
like there should be a video on that
song like yeah they never did a video
for that
i wish they did it would have been so
amazing we just got the album cover that
had her
in the trunk yeah and that was on the
slim shady lp yeah yeah yeah yeah the
second one was him and uh
sitting down but yeah man um you get
canceled
i don't give a [ __ ] about anything going
on right now
i don't give a [ __ ] about who your
favorite rapper is i don't care
like none of this stuff matters to me
anymore
i think it's irrelevant where i'm at i'm
really in 1984 right now when i made
this project
i kind of wanted to be in that era i
wanted to try
time travel to 1984 and
i'm stuck there and i enjoy it here i
enjoy where i
am you know i i bought a house for my
mom and dad i bought a house for me that
i don't live in
i still live in my old apartment people
still wait for me in my
old apartment ask for pictures i take
the picture and i walk to the store come
back
like as if nothing is happening i drive
my cars and i don't want to change
anything in my life
the music comes out i don't
i don't want a house full of my friends
doing drugs
doing tick tocks like i was about to say
that's just the hollywood
gauntlet right now yeah [ __ ] house
full of a bunch of tick tockers on coke
yeah exactly that's literally the
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yeah that's not me yeah i'm
saying that's not
just random aspiring artists moving to
l.a and then bunkering down in a room
and
yeah [ __ ] the hills with 11 other
guys who have [ __ ]
yeah it's like it's like the worst like
i'm not
that's that's that's so crazy you say
that because people who don't who aren't
in
first of all who don't live here and who
are in our uh industry
that is literally so much of what's
going on in la right now
yeah it's crazy i mean good for them you
know what i mean like i'm not mad
at them but just not my world i don't
give a [ __ ] like i
rather just be home watching movies like
you know what i mean
like when was the last time you saw a
movie like belly when you're never gonna
see it again you're not you're just not
and i'm saying now they're redoing fresh
prince of bel-air they're going to ruin
it
they ruined lion king they ruined full
house they ruined full house they're
going to ruin
everything everything that we've ever
loved we live long enough to see it get
ruined
every single artist that we've ever
loved we live long enough to watch them
go on instagram and completely throw
everything down the drain
it's such [ __ ] i just want to get
popping i want to delete everything and
go away
like i'm not where i want to be yet
because i still want to release the
music and i need social media for my
label
so i could do it but the best part is
when i'm completely done
and i'm officially done just release the
music and get the [ __ ] out the way and
go
hide that's all i want to do you know
what i mean and i'm not angry
i'm not unhappy i'm so [ __ ] happy i
have a dog and [ __ ] i
feed my nephews i think kind of dog you
have i have a golden doodle and he's the
[ __ ] man he's like
i have better conversations with him
than i do humans yeah i have a
i have a pump well my wife has a
pomeranian that's by default my
pomeranian and i named him after the big
lebowski
okay his name's jeffrey lebowski sick
sick
my dog's preston i named him after blank
check fire
yeah blank check tone lok is in black
jack
yeah i love that [ __ ] yo i missed the i
just missed those not like early
90s kids movies like little giants and
[ __ ]
like why don't they make some [ __ ] like
that and they don't they don't
they don't like so [ __ ] you know but
like they don't they just don't they
don't they're not creative and
that goes back to what i'm trying to
explain to you 1984 it's about a kid who
goes to his friend danny's house
and then he's showing him his new crib
and he goes i found this time machine i
don't know if it works but the guy that
they say died i don't think he died i
think i know where he went
puts me in the time machine sends me to
1984 and then the album starts
and like when did you feel like that
last time you felt like that was
probably universal studios like you've
never felt that way you know what i'm
saying so
it's a it's a nice uh mental vacation
for people to jump into during these
times
exactly at play and just get the [ __ ]
out
get in your car and feel like you're in
the time you said something earlier
about people buying spotify streams
yeah i know that how much of a thing is
that
it's like 90 95
of people that are like popping are
buying spotify streams and then they get
their music to be playlisted
and these [ __ ] would get like
100 to 200 million plays
a month and you're like how the [ __ ] are
they doing that
like why aren't there bigger songs from
like
three years ago fast as this the song's
not even that good
it's like they're trying to make it look
like they're getting bigger and better
but it's really the backwards well
that's what i wanted to ask you because
you as an artist
you've been on both sides of it right
because like tuma like really
a lot of your early singles you know
2017
um like benefited a lot
from real like like you said when rap
caviar
was really like changing careers yes yes
um you know he took a chance on you
because at the time
you weren't that wasn't popping and now
that doesn't happen
if you're not popping or you don't have
some sort of social like you're not
making it on rap caviar i don't know but
i'm curious like
what would you say to like an artist who
like because it almost
unfortunately now if you're gonna get
signed
i don't even know if you should get
signed but if you're gonna get signed by
a major label
you gotta do most of the work before
they they come into the picture
i mean right like it's like they want
you to make sure that you got all this
this this is this and this going before
honestly i love
my rca label i love them as humans
right i love peter edge i love them so
much
i really do truly could look at that
man's eyes
and know that he believes in me it's not
[ __ ] you know
i love mark pitts i love everyone at the
rca building because i know they believe
in me
right you understand it's not [ __ ]
um but
you know a lot of people don't have that
i mean i'm shooting i'm shooting videos
for a lot of money you know they give me
money they send me money each time i
need money rca takes care of me so
now a lot of artists do that they sign
and then they have to do it themselves
so you just basically sign
to watch to have somebody watch you pop
off so they can take your money it's
the most backwards thing i've ever seen
that's what i was trying to get to yeah
yeah so um
it really depends on your situation you
know um
you know my my situation is different it
took me 10 years to be where i'm at
um seven years to get my deal
hopped on the plane it turned up at a
studio at um
office no one plays their own music for
people like you by the way
thank you man i mean i love my music
there's an art to that though like
yo no matter like when you play your
[ __ ]
you're getting everybody on your level
bro cause you'll be [ __ ] it's that
energy i was talking about earlier i
just love
i love them everyone should be as
confident and and into their own [ __ ] as
you
honestly though if you're not you know i
look at my you have kids so
you should know what it's like like you
know i look at my my music is like my
child
you know like like when i show it off
i'm proud of it
yeah and you don't show your child
unless you're not proud of your child
but like
you don't show your child and be like
yeah this is my child that's it throw
him out the window you know what i mean
like
nah this is my child and i'm gonna rep
for for my child and i'm gonna dance
with my child then i'm gonna show you
why
my child is important so
that's i mean yeah that's i think that's
the attitude most people should have
um so with this project
uh being like a passion project i know
you
i know you're working a lot like how
much um
and i'm assuming you didn't plan on
putting this project out at the
beginning of this pandemic or was this
always kind of in the cards for you like
i mean i don't know i wanted to put it
out but i didn't think the pandemic
thing was gonna happen
i wanted to put it out like was this the
plan to be your next album
or or no or was there other music no
that's another album okay so there's
that's what i was going to ask you
another
got to be some more yeah there's another
album that
you know rca didn't fund the 1984 album
i i funded it rca didn't
um
rca didn't give me the push almost like
they treated it like it was like a
mixtape or something i guess yeah like
rc
i still love ourselves hey something if
something pops off on this we'll get it
yeah this is clearly your project and
let's see what it does
rca they believe in me and
one thing that rca does which is great
which labels don't do is they allow
artists to be themselves and do what
they want what the [ __ ] they want to do
you know
and um rca allowed me to do what i
wanted with this album
and i didn't get the big label push
on 1984 it's more of like
my [ __ ] but surprisingly i put it out
and it's killing it's killing and it's
like
the people are losing their minds man
people i mean i feel like it's a
cleansing of
of of uh everyone's palate sonically
i'm thinking about that off the camera
just like
with with what's going on in the world
clubs aren't going on
yeah like people are looking for
like music to sit with exactly like dude
like if i were to die
this [ __ ] would be like my big one
you understand like if i'm gone like in
no exaggeration if
something happens to me this album is
gonna be
legendary classic timeless iconic yeah
you know what i'm saying and and if
you're not if you don't feel like that
about your project
you shouldn't put it out that's fair and
this is not me bragging about me this is
me to having
this is me with rolling stone magazine
interviews
uh forbes doing doing some of the
greatest biggest interviews with some of
the most relevant
interviewers of all time that have have
interviewed icons
telling me this is an iconic album so
it's
so the way i feel about it is through
the people telling me not me telling
myself you know what i'm saying i can't
toot my own horn that only could get me
as far as
getting me somewhere but when the people
that have the right credentials
tell you yo this is this is an
incredible project and
it kind of makes you you know this is
okay
i'm saying stairs album which is my
first one is my
late registration okay or college
dropout i was gonna say that's kanye's
second album but okay no but no
because i have four play okay yeah yeah
true true true so that's mine you had a
lot of singles
that's what yeah that's my college
dropout for play and
my late registration stairs and let's
just skip a few
albums and um gashy is my graduation
this is your 808s this is my 808s
changing changing music
exactly is to change music exactly this
is my edo this is my eighth wave yeah i
would say 808 and jesus
are two like albums kanye put out that
just sonically changed
like the direction of like hip hop or
music
yeah my my to my doctor was fancy as
well yeah
of course of course i just mean in terms
of like sound sounds yes yes
you know what i mean i agree i agree and
uh my next one
my next album is gonna be my my um
my mind my doctors to fancy mine
my version fire and then after that it's
gonna be
um my jesus
and then you don't know where i'm gonna
go with it but i just the thing is the
key is to never make the same song twice
never make the same sounding album i
always wanted to make my [ __ ] sound
like i want to make when i'm in the
world was
in the theme i'm in a theme my next
project i wanted to feel like 90s dance
music
you know okay like i wanted to feel like
a gay club
like that's how i want my music to feel
like i wanted to feel like
shout out to all my gay fans too like
they shout out you know shout out to all
my gay fans like
like they have some of the most
incredible taste ever
ever and they put me on all the time
like listen to this listen to that
and i kind of like like i like i
appreciate
how like how much love i get from not
from everyone but
so sonically you want to go and like i'm
just when i think of like
what you just said i don't know why
knight of the roxbury just popped in my
head
yeah yeah yeah that's that's true now
that's roxbury like
those kind of vibes yeah like you know
what i'm saying like
like ace bro like that's that's the
[ __ ]
that's the way you can pull the uh
the will pharaoh or what's the other
guy's name the tiny guy
something can i don't know he's locked
up yeah oh is he i think so yeah damn
that'd be great but man like
bro like we're not here forever man
you know like do what you love bro like
people i swear if you see how fast
people move on
after somebody dies in 2020 you think
twice before thinking about what someone
else is going to say about you
that's fair man another thing i think
that's important for people who don't
necessarily
uh have have the uh that aren't aware of
your come up
like we spoke about this a few years ago
but i think
it's like just really inspiring how your
music career kind of
almost stopped right you were
you had a scholarship to play football
yeah i played football i had a
scholarship i dropped out
and then um i was going to register for
school again and then peter rosenberg
played my song on the radio really
driving really nice i pulled over
told my mom i'm not going back to school
kept going got my deal i got
shelved i had to find a way out of my
deal i got idea my documentary what was
your original deal
with joe jason lava records okay if you
want
there's a documentary out right now did
i just you know just put it out yeah
it's called now you know check it out
it's a documentary i put together
and now netflix has called and they're
interested in doing the whole movie so
that would be crazy
yeah so um you don't know i might go
into the movie business you don't i i
that's my dream like
doing movies and stuff like that i mean
[ __ ] i feel like [ __ ] now's the time bro
yeah um you i've also heard you allude
to
being around before you were gashy
obviously you were always gashy but
before you were known as gashy on a on a
big lit
uh level being around a lot of uh
the biggest artists in the world but
before they were the biggest artists in
the world yeah yeah yeah yeah
always and maybe either a giving them
some sauce
helping them on records yeah and always
i've always have
had so you've like like did you like
were there was ever a point in time
where you were just writing for people
or you were
yeah i mean i was writing for people i
was i was um
let's just say because i don't like
saying too much especially about my past
i feel like i
i i feel like you i feel like if you're
watching this interview
i want you to completely kill me
or kill the person that you knew of you
of me right kill him completely because
that old me is like officially expired
i'm i'm officially somewhere else
but like but like i um
like i wrote i wrote music for people
yes i did
i um i've helped i've helped so many
people out and i've seen them become
millionaires
and blow up and forget me
and i've seen it so many times that i
feel i feel
nothing towards it and when they see me
they can't look at me in my eyes
they look down so damn i mean
it is what it is i mean it's not i feel
bad for them
i don't feel bad for myself anymore i
feel bad for them because um
they've completely lost themselves i
feel bad for them you know
they've completely killed themselves you
know what i'm saying and i'm
you're you're you're still you i'm still
me and i could look into a mirror and
know that that's me i don't have to put
on an act i'm not worried i could sleep
at night without
taking no drugs i'm fine like you know
what i'm saying so
um i feel bad for them you know and
i'm sure every time i see them they they
they wish that um it never happened
that's fair i mean you also too have
like i feel like
you know um there's very few
[Music]
in the in the music industry there's a
lot of acquaintances right there's a lot
of people that we come in contact with
they're like yeah i'm cool with them
like you know
yeah let's get up let's work never
happens let's do lunch
right but there's like very few friends
like and i feel like dj snake is one of
those guys for you
yes my brother man um the dude and
i know you guys creatively have had a
sick history
yeah he's my guy he's my guy because i'm
snake
snake's my guy man um i was gonna say
who else on that like who else is on
that list for you
reason people don't understand the
reason why i'm so close with snake has
nothing to do with just the music i
think um
i had a warrant for my arrest and i got
into trouble in new york
and um i don't want to get too deep
into it because you know thankfully the
case got dropped and
i don't want to bring it back up it was
a nightmare and um
yeah i handled my business you know as a
as a brother
you know i handled my business um
someone
attacked my sister and i handled my
business
and do what you're supposed to do
exactly and um
i think i handled my business and took
it a little too far so uh
um i had to escape the country and
go to iceland so what year was this
this was 2015.
[ __ ] yeah so i basically handled my
business
and i need to bail money and dj snake
put the money up when all my friends
didn't pick up the phone and want to
give me money so
i'm loyal to that man even if he pulls
some weird [ __ ]
i'm still loyal to him based on what he
did oh he held you down yeah he held me
down at that point where i needed him so
you know that man could that man could
shoot me and i still want to be mad at
him so
what's that i mean there's a very very
rare uh
friendships to have man yeah iceland
what
i mean i feel like iceland uh is a
country that
is not icy no it's cold
oh it is cold what was it like like like
because you're
you i feel like you originally like a
lot of your core fan base was overseas
yes still is
right you have a huge following overseas
like 1984
just changed everything 1984
just changed everything now i'm having
fans in america
well you have fans in america of course
but like it's getting i hear what you're
saying it's getting to that point where
it's like
i can't go to starbucks yes in america
anymore
so it's like it's becoming where it's
like i'm becoming super successful on
both
areas which is weird because i loved
feeling like a celebrity in europe and
then coming back and just
trying to being able to just relax turn
it off you know
um snake i love chris brown
chris brown is um chris brown to me
is the most talented uh
super artist we all right check this out
a lot of people are gonna
not understand well everything you're
about to say i i think i say all the
time about him but go ahead
okay so people gonna get upset but suck
my
suck my dick i don't care the thing is
we judge the man based on his past and
what he's done and and [ __ ] you
like okay we all make mistakes right
i don't think he as a human being
see like we have legends like the
beatles and stuff like that
you know we have michael jackson we have
the we have legendary artists and i love
that we do have that on earth it's
amazing
but nobody can last
with chris brown in on the dance floor
or
keep up with him musically or
chris brown will dunk on your favorite
artists and put his balls on their
[ __ ] head
chris brown will outdance them chris
brown will out sing them chris brown
will outdo them
anyway chris brown will [ __ ] your
favorite artist [ __ ] in front of them
and they won't do nothing
the chris brown is one of the greatest
[ __ ] things that's ever happened
in history of the world on earth this
man
i've seen chris brown float in the air
like float in the air
just levitate no [ __ ] i'm being
serious i seen chris brown
float in the [ __ ] air with
timberlands on in a bubble jacket
stay in the air for six seconds i've
seen chris brown do things that a human
is not supposed to be doing
chris brown is the most talented person
he's an
alien and something's crazy the fact
that
he's just too good for earth and just
give him his flowers now he's made
mistakes
move the [ __ ] on you know i mean move
the [ __ ] on like
he's made mistakes and we get it but
like stop judging him off of that like
let's talk about what he's bro
so many hits so much [ __ ] that this man
does is so special
and i apologize for getting crazy but
like dude like
he is so talented and it's like people
try to
downplay it as if it's not there it's
like yo bro the sky is [ __ ] blue
and you can tell me it's any color you
want but it's blue but it's [ __ ] blue
you know what i'm saying you got all
these [ __ ] you know the industry is
full of [ __ ] shine
and that's that industry equals [ __ ]
shine what [ __ ] shine it's
all these artists are [ __ ] and they
shine it and they make you believe is
good
chris brown is not [ __ ] shine chris
brown is what happens when you give
money to an actual talent artist
i i always say this about chris brown
he's probably the most talented human
being
that has ever that we've ever seen
because like you said
not only is he the best dancer he could
he could paint a mural on the side of
his house bro
you know what i'm saying like like his
the level of artistry and talent like
you could say whatever you want about
him
but talent-wise there's nobody
we've ever seen that's on his level no
and so i've been seeing like
and no disrespect to drake because drake
is obviously a jedi but like i've been
seeing like a tweet going around that i
think fat joke called drake like our
michael jackson i'm like no it's chris
brown
chris brown and unfortunately like you
said
there's like a tainted aura still around
chris brown when those conversations
happen but it's
crazy when he is literally the most
talented human being that's probably
ever made music
he can do everything better than
everybody everybody
and he can paint he can
play
so i've been working with chris brown on
this uh breezy album coming out and
he's incredible and i've never seen an
artist go
in the booth without writing anything
i thought i was the only one who did
that and the only reason why i started
doing that was because i used to work
with nipsey and he taught me that
i had a session with nipsc and i saw he
didn't write and then i started doing
that where i would
say something cut and then punch in and
the way chris brown records
like you know what i'm saying like i'm
not gonna get too deep into topic but
he's just so talented that
it's a shame the world it's a shame how
the world tries to like
downplay it as if like right
like after this interview there's gonna
be people on the comments or people can
be on my tweets on my instagram
bitching got me it's just gonna be full
of [ __ ] people that are like
got nothing going on in their life and
they're coming at me because of what i
said you know what i'm saying it's a
bunch of those idiots but like
like i just i i just want i i
want to give chris brown his flowers
well he can still smell them and
i just want to continue to do that and i
i want to also say
like as somebody i've been critical with
chris brown's personal decisions
throughout the years
and i'm not even necessarily like the
like i'm a grown ass man so i'm not like
riding around bumping
chris brown a lot of times like i'm not
like the biggest fan of like chris brown
but look you got to acknowledge
he is a alien bro yeah exactly like
exactly can you not watch this and you
know there was this versus battle [ __ ]
and i'm like
at you know i was thinking like
chris brown versus usher but like breezy
has a bag that like
he could get into that like he can do 60
records
like yo man you know what i'm saying
like he could like yo
the features the the like just the rap
and [ __ ] like the versus thing right
you're talking about that
yeah like usher's i don't think anybody
could beat chris brown in the verses
but it goes back to what i was saying
maybe drake but
no no no but i know what i'm saying that
like that might be the
the only like no way but i think i'm
glad that he turned that [ __ ] down
i'm telling you there's no way there's
no way no drake
no nothing nobody nobody could outbeat
chris brown nobody
and from deuces to nobody's dancing
no no bro i'm just telling you he's
incredible he's incredible like he just
floated out a young thug collab album
right with that with no roll out and go
crazy you know just hit number one on
race bro
say you love me is one of the most
incredible songs on that project
go crazy is incredible he continues to
make hits he continues
effortlessly it's so light work for him
i i just
i just you know we're gonna move on but
chris i i love chris and i think
i think he's incredible and he's one of
my friends and
and i'm so thankful to say he's my face
called me checked up on me during the
pandemic make sure my family's good
right
always checks up on me like such a such
a big-hearted person you understand and
he's incredible another person that's
really dope is um skrillex um nice guy
sonny's a sweetheart man um uh but you
know adele
adele is incredible an incredible big
heart big hearted person
um how crazy is it that like adele who's
again one of those people who might have
like maybe the best voice we've ever
heard
like maybe like top five yeah it's like
the last icon like jesus christ like you
know that's like another one
you're talking about like when someone's
so talented like that's the right person
who got the deal and got the money like
holy [ __ ] yeah
she's one of the greatest singers of all
time yeah but these are these are the
people that are like
incredible incredible incredible people
incredible
you and adele have a a solid
relationship she's she's
uh she's the person i met that i'm
friends with she's awesome um
um um i like sam smith sam smith is cool
um
well so i'm friends with uh
i'm friends with uh i know i know french
always
you know yeah fresh montana what about
the
other big albanian in music you in
action got any sort of uh
so me and action bronson made a song
together he's supposed to be on the
gashi album
i uh he's supposed to be on my interlude
um and um
yeah i um i never put it on the album
and you guys are both like such great
dudes
i love him he's he's incredible shout
out to him he's losing weight getting
his health together he's so he's he's a
special soul man
so he was supposed to be on the album
yeah i got together with
um actually branch and as as uh his
loft in in queens and i was watching his
paintings because i paint as well
and he paints so uh um he was just
smoking weed there and he was like
we were like we knew each other the
first time i met him it was me him and r
kelly
and we were just hanging out in
manhattan whoa yeah it was just
yo that sounds like an amazing just
one day recreate that in cartoons yeah
it was just so weird
it was like something that noisy was
doing and we were there and then um
we didn't really get a chance to talk
but he always showed me love and always
gave me
like a heads up and always talked to me
and um
the second time we met we met we met up
in the street he knew about me he knew i
was all being coming up and he's very
competitive action bronson very much he
don't like keeping people around him his
circle is super tight so he sees his
other band guy he's like i don't know
how i feel about this boom boom boom
so i'm popping off my ears going off i'm
all over times square so he invites me
he's like okay he's booming let me just
bring him in see what's up so i i go to
his apartment smoking weed having a
conversation with me his leg is broken
or something
yes he's just going through it and um
you know uh i played in the 80s
album not the album that was coming out
but i played them
i mean i loved it he's like you're not a
rapper
and i was like i'm not and he's like
[ __ ] i thought you were a rapper
and then he opened up and like he's just
the sweetheart he's like
he's the best he's the [ __ ] best i
love him and he cut this verse for me
and i
i never got we never got a chance to
make the album because it was so late
but i still have it and it's just it's
it's just it's so funny it's like i'm
just gonna play it it's exclusive
no one's ever heard this
[Music]
sounds hard bro yeah this is the
interlude
uh the outro to my first it's the outro
to my first
gashi album
[Music]
make sure you get that gashy album
because uh
a lot of people slept on the outro this
song was incredible
shout out to logan hyde
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm not
[Music]
double-headed eagle on the handle
[Music]
you know i'm stronger
[Music]
[Music]
you got to figure out something to put
that verse on bro
because that's that's one of them action
verses he didn't just give you a
throwaway bro
i think he realized that was a moment
yeah it was a moment man because he came
through
he did strong as both the steiner
brothers man come on bro
he's as i rise like michael jackson
that's the way to start a verse
yeah he said he said uh hand on the
heater with the two-headed eagle which
is our band yeah
thing you know what i'm saying that's
crazy yeah i love it are you gonna are
you gonna i mean you got to repurpose
that verse man i'm not you never know i
got i got to link up with action man
that [ __ ] is fire it is and you know
what man
i i love him dude i love him i respect
him and
and i'm so proud of him and he's losing
weight now again
yeah man he's getting his [ __ ] together
and congratulations on his son
and he's you know for the record like
he's always like had his [ __ ] together
it's not like but you know i just think
that you know we all have our advices
and food for me is is my advice mine too
but he always had a [ __ ] together but
like just to see him trying to be like
healthier to live
longer for his son for his son it's a
beautiful beautiful thing
and i'm just proud of him you know i i
love him i love to see my people do well
and
and and i'm winning i'm not i'm not
there's not a conversation
of me as a loser a lot of people say
nice things about people when they're
losing
i'm actually a [ __ ] winner right now
this is me talking as a winner
talk and and and yeah i would love to
see you guys
officially do something i mean you guys
have done something yeah but yeah
uh i just think uh action's one of my
favorite rappers and yeah
um that's dope yo look man quick break
from the podcast and tell you about odd
socks all right they're our official
sponsor they support what we do here at
the bootleg kit podcast
all right they got them nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com if you want to
support what i do the bootleghead
podcast
then support our partners odd socks go
buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks um you spoke
about how you
meeting nipsey changed your life yeah
kind of obviously you know nipsey's one
of the greats
rest in peace man he was a close friend
of mine um
still can't believe man it's about to be
two years next year in march
um what what was your interaction with
nipsey and how did that affect you
because isn't that crazy energy
you don't think that's crazy the fact
that like i'm the i'm becoming one of
the
pop artists like one of the big pop
artists like i'm becoming like
i'm becoming like phil collins like the
new york times had
phil collins it's a whole nother type of
pop we're talking too yeah yeah
like like timeless iconic pop right
and um i'm becoming
that and uh
so say okay so say this right she
becomes the new like george michael phil
collins sting of this generation where
i'm like
timeless and everyone's like coming to
my shows are so down like
i'm like i'm doing the garden yeah just
saying bringing garth brooks out
yeah like twice like doing like right
sell the garden twice
right becoming legendary kids are losing
their mind and becoming like [ __ ]
insane right to say there's videos of me
and nipsey in the studio after that
how insane is that story yeah no i think
it's a it's a you know your come up man
it's it's insane coming up as a rapper
out of new york
it's insane yeah it's crazy you know i
met this guy
through shout out to my friend austin
rosen he made it possible he brought
nipsey to the studio and
austin austin manages post malone like
he's like
he's the reason for pokemon being as big
as he is uh austin rosen um
brought nipsey to his studio brought me
in played the record and if she loved it
told me
i was dope enough to to really make it
happen and after i met nipsey
nipsey i felt it was real and i could
drop out and make it happen he made me
feel that way
so you met so nipsy was coming in to lay
a verse for you or just to work
so nipsey came into the studio with uh
this guy named johnny
and um shapes yeah and shout out
yeah austin was like i want to get
nipsey on this record i want to play him
the record so we played in record he's
like yo this is tight this was your
record this is my record yeah and then
we got nipsey's like this just fire we
just jumped in the booth cut it real
quick and then
he's telling me you know i mean like i
was telling him like i really want to do
this [ __ ] and he was like oh yeah
it should fire bro like you can do it
and like
like nipsey was my favorite upcoming
rapper yeah
so i was telling austin about him i was
like i'll get him on a verse like it's
nothing because he was
just coming up so you could get nipsey
universe you know and um
because i looked at i was looking at
nipsey like our generation snoop
yeah you know i think when he first came
out that was kind of like
they look very similar they look similar
they're both very similar
not similar but they had very each of
them had a very distinct tone
yeah and they look like the you know
they look like he's a [ __ ] and right
he was just so hard like all skinny
skinny with the with the plaids and the
jeans at the converse like it was just
so snoop
and i was like yo this guy is going to
be our snoop our icon
and i was like he's going to be the
biggest
and everybody around me is like what the
hell are you talking about dawg i was
like
yo can i get him on a verse it's like i
can make that call that's nothing
you know what i mean everyone around is
like it's not a big deal but
i think i think you know what like not
to toot my own horn man but
i think i have the vision to see
somebody in 20 years
to see somebody in 10 years to see
somebody i could look at somebody and
know if they're going to be somebody or
not in the music business
yeah man nipsey was one of those guys uh
the first time i met him was in oh nine
he came in freestyle on my show in boise
idaho when i was doing radio and boise
wow that was my first full-time job
crazy and uh killed it
yeah he had a mixtape out called bullets
ain't got no name oh i love that i love
still play it yeah part one and two
right two is my [ __ ] roll the windows up
oh my god but yeah rest in peace to
nipsey you mentioned being around um
austin early were you i feel like
generic fans of music might uh compare
you and posty together yeah
just because you guys have a lot of
tattoos yeah just because we're both fat
white
boys fair enough um
what like were you around post early on
yeah i mean i
uh i was friends with um post i was
friends with austin
um i was friends with them we'd ride
around in my mom's car and like
play music and we had like very similar
tastes like
we like the same [ __ ] and early on like
you said that you could see uh
kind of people ahead of their time did
you did you see post like and be like
you know hey
this guy could be one of the biggest
artists in the world um
i didn't see that post i knew that i
knew he was a special soul
like he's a good dude he's a great guy
yeah and um
he was just a special energy and like
we'd laugh you know he's
this kid was this prior to him moving to
l.a
he moved to l.a already at the time but
like you know we just drive around my
mom's car and listen to the ipod and he
played me his stuff and we played he was
in my video
his for my first video you know it was
just weird like
you know yeah i think me and posty kind
of faded off
when uh people started comparing us and
it became weird
so like i feel like that's somebody who
you know
when you talk about like y'all i was
around a lot of the biggest artists
early on
like do you feel like you might have
maybe had some sort of influence on post
early on
i don't know i i you know i don't know i
did i first heard him
you you probably know charlie handsome
ryan yeah i love charlie
yeah so ryan like like ryan's from
phoenix where i'm from yeah um
and he had reached out to me like when i
was doing radio in tampa in 2014.
or ended for 2014 and was like dude
white iverson
i'm at the time ryan was telling me he
was managing post yeah i mean everybody
was
everybody was managing posting something
yeah rex kudo
dre you know whatever but yeah yeah it's
just
it's interesting because i do feel like
you guys uh
like you like what you just said about
his energy and what i said about your
energy earlier yeah
we have we're very similar you know
we're very similar we smile a lot
and um we have similar music tastes
and what we like singing and hitting
same similar melodies and you know it's
um another reason why like i'm happy at
this 80s album is because like
you can't compare me to anybody to
anybody
when i when i sing the way i do with the
80s stuff and you know
you know posters around and you know a
lot a lot of artists you know like even
with khalid man you know
like khalid i was driving around khalid
played me his first album before he
became anybody you know
wow yeah i feel like khalid is another
one of the early spotify success stories
exactly like i was just i was blessed
enough to be around
all these artists and learn from them as
well as much as they learn from me i
learn from them and um
i'm so happy that
my career is going the way it is i i've
i think 1984 might be the time i think
1980
i think this interview is the last
interview i do before i get ruined
well don't don't try not to get ruined
when you say get ruined what do you mean
actually specify
like i might blow up and just become
generic and become walmart
if it happens the right way i might
become target
do you want i mean that's not what i
want i have no choice i have no option
that's true so it's almost like once you
blow up it's like
i feel like uh i just i felt this way
about
the baby right so the baby i've been a
fan of the baby for a long time before
anybody knew the [ __ ] he was we
interviewed him
2017. this is when he was doing his
diaper [ __ ] at south by southwest yeah
and i [ __ ] with his music because he
was talking about moving packs and
selling weed and like i come from that
world so i was like i related to his
[ __ ]
yeah and like now
i'm not excited to hear new music from
the baby anymore because i
he's so big that i kind of just like
i'm like okay well like what i love them
for he's not really doing anymore
like i'll hear the [ __ ] i need to hear
yeah but it's just not but he's like
target now
yes you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah i know what it's like you know and
it's not and it's not like he's
not making dope [ __ ] still it's just
like you know it's like
i i what you just said it's like it's
not up to you it's not
you know and if you with any amount of
certain commercial success like
that just kind of happens what happens
here like um my my
boy's little sister is like
like she was the biggest billy eilish
fan
and now she's [ __ ] walmart and now
i'm like yo billy dropped a new song
uh i'm not really into billy anymore i
think we mentally do that
kanye i think was the last artist for me
that like just because like what we
talked about earlier with him would be
like i just want
i can't wait to see what he's doing even
i feel like travis to a certain extent
but like kanye
i've lost that with him uh recently
because i really was not a fan of
the jesus king [ __ ] and yeah i'm okay
like i said man like
kanye i like became walmart but didn't
like
yeah it was the walmart i wanted to go
to exactly exactly
exactly go buy some [ __ ] cargo shorts
and a vizio
i just i don't remember the last time
i felt the way i felt when i turned the
tv on and i saw
kanye west wearing leather performing
black skinhead
that hasn't happened for me in a very
long time and that's all i'm gonna say
i'ma leave it at that no one's
impressive i love travis scott
good day he does what he does and that's
amazing but
i can't wait to see if he changes the
sound do you understand what i'm saying
um i'm just not looking i'm not you know
like the last time where you were like
[ __ ]
when was the last time you said shut the
[ __ ] up don't talk to me
my headphones are on i am going to be
focused
right now when was that that has never
happened
you listen to it like oh here we go
generic [ __ ] again
i think when we're talking about the
upper echelon of artists i i don't just
i don't disagree with you
i think that um you know there's artists
that i'm like that with but they're like
some boom bap like
like like yo [ __ ] west side guns pray
for paris is out leave me the [ __ ] alone
you know what i mean
but you love that it's good that's good
that you still find something that you
love you know you
you like that i mean you know um you
you have to you i feel like i feel like
i'm doing that for my fans right now and
that's what makes me happy
my fans are like shut up he's dropping
something
and i'm gonna listen to it because i
know it's going to be
a different sound and that's what i got
to continue to do it the minute i
stopped doing yeah the minute i stopped
doing that
it's over for me dog hey look i also
think that there's a good chance that we
look back at this interview in a year
yeah and that your project let's say you
know
like you said influential people are
loving it so
we might look back in a year and like
the 80s sound
is going to be all over a bunch of
people's [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like
now you will you get the credit for it
probably not no i never do
but you know i mean we'll see but i can
definitely see like
even just the sonics of like the
production and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like
i could see like people tapping in with
that now because they're like oh
oh exactly this can work exactly i mean
you know what
one thing i admired about reading in all
the
the magazines after i dropped the album
was
authentic real
original the words that i was looking
for
was uh these artists
release sounding similar sounding 80
sounding but
not authentic copycats and
you read what i'm what they write about
my [ __ ] it's authentic
real original and that's the things that
i was looking for and that's
i hit it on the head where i was that it
was not sounded like a copycat
and i made a sound that people loved and
was original i brought
that i brought a sound that was modern
80s sound you and i are movie buffs you
said something earlier how the movies
aren't the same anymore no
and they're not no um but what's the
last movie you saw that like you really
really
[ __ ] with where you were like yeah
this is uh this is a special one right
here
um for me it was uncut gems now i also
happen to be a turtle
i'm a degenerate sports gambler so i
related to that movie oh i hated it
something crazy it was so annoying i
hated it it was a very stressful
it caused me anxiety there's so much
anxiety if you watch that movie and
you've lived that
you're like [ __ ] yeah the only the best
part about
that movie was having um have a gordette
yeah it was kind of cool kg was in there
he was a great actor in it but uh the
best part
it was uh my boy greg yuna yeah he's a
great uh he's an amazing jeweler he's
incredible he's one of my great friends
and he believed in me i love him
and uh but yeah
that was that movie i'll tell you the
story after we stopped this interview
oh about that movie yeah i'll tell you
that's a specific movie yeah i'll tell
you a crazy story
why are you sports gambler no no but
i'll tell you a crazy story like
um no but what was that what was the
last movie for you you saw that like
really hit you like that you're not okay
this is this is this is fire like
um and not fire like you know at the
because it's on netflix but like just
some [ __ ] that you're like oh this is
some [ __ ] i'm gonna watch in 20 years
oh wow if any
i don't know man like the movies
recently i don't know
dude like
it's like difficult like i watch only
old movies i don't really
i watch the new ones but i don't care
bad boys three was kind of trash
which is horrible she was terrible man
all this [ __ ] is garbage
um um
all right people hate it i'm saying let
me just say this
people hated
the the um the queen movie
okay bohemian rhapsody yes they hated it
everyone hated it i actually liked it
i liked it and dude killed it the actor
who killed it they got it
at the museum i don't know his name yeah
um
that was a good movie the elton john
movie not so much
yo shout out to ellen john actually he's
he's a legend
i wasn't a fan you know that's one of my
biggest inspirations
when i shoot videos i try to look like
him okay
what'd you think of that movie it was
good it was uh i just
think they should have gave a heads up
saying it was a musical
true we ain't getting no heads up you
just like saw the trailer and you like
dived in here
yeah what the [ __ ] then you go in there
and then you go it's like oh
[ __ ] it's a musical but i love ellen
john and i um
i love him very much and if he didn't
exist i don't think i'd be here honestly
because he's influenced me so much
what about are you um like like are you
a big tv guy like do you binge watch
series and [ __ ] like
man i'm right now i'm watching first
principle there just rewind he runs
and i love uh you know my favorite
cartoons hey arnold
hey arnold was fired yeah i got the
tattoo on my leg but
liar yeah i love hey arnold so much you
know
doug two of the most slept on yeah doug
was cool i never really got into it like
that but like hey arnold is my [ __ ] like
hey arnold is my [ __ ] rocket powers my
[ __ ]
but like i just rewatched the wire with
my wife oh the wire oh
i was friends with the guy um panama hmm
he always believed in me um i have the
weirdest connections in the world
i'm friends with the weirdest people i
really am i'm i'm friends with
i'm friends i'm connected with i've been
through the craziest my life is insane
my life is insane i'm friends with the
most you would never think i'm friends
with these people
yo man i mean i didn't know you were on
the run in iceland that's [ __ ] crazy
i know that's nice that's iceland but
yeah what an interesting place to choose
to go to
i know but life life is crazy right now
you know and um
i still can't believe we're we're in a
situation we're in you know
um but no one can run away right now
and that's what's scary we're trapped in
the world right now and
2020 is the new in 1984 and
um if you ever read george um
if you ever if you yeah if you've ever
read the orwell book
um it's kind of crazy the fact that i
dropped the 1984
uh album after i recorded it in 2015 now
because
these are the dark times we're living in
and i think i pray
that we're still alive after the
elections election is going to be
interesting man
yeah it is going to be uh like you said
it could be the it feels like it could
be like the climax to the end of the
world coming up
yeah or the end of the world as we know
it yes so i'm just happy that i released
a project i saw my billboard on sunset
across the street from the chateau
which is i saw that yeah yeah because uh
my third album is going to be recorded
in the chateau
okay yeah so this is exclusive stuff
that i'm telling you actually i've never
told anyone
um third album was recorded on in the
chateau
because of uh john belushi where that's
where he passed
yeah and he's a big big influence and
big inspiration because he was the first
albanian
male in hollywood wow i didn't know that
i didn't even know he was he was
albanian yeah i have him tattered on me
as well
and you know have you met his brother
yes i've actually
i'm from jim um yeah jim jim had a run
too man
that's you know i've had lunch with him
i'm friends with his kids and stuff like
we talk on instagram
so you and the belushi's got some some
uh some
some genuine relationships yeah i've met
them met his brother
couple times but as far as like john
like john john just
probably a lot of inspiration as a kid
be like yo somebody from where i'm from
yeah has made it into hollywood it's
never happened i mean look at the
albanian artists
don't do alipa or you know i didn't even
know dual leap it was albanian
but then again doesn't matter that's
look what you're saying
i i don't listen to alipa but hold on
though look look what you're saying
did you know rita ora was i did not
exactly look what you're saying did you
yeah we'll end it there so there's like
i just think it's dope that you rep that
[ __ ] like you know what i'm saying i
think it's important
make sure make sure that you send me
that clip exactly
how what just happened right now send it
to me because i want to post it on my
social media
because see my country right now is not
on the map
on apple apple's not putting my country
on a map kosovo
and you got all these girl artists right
now
saying complaining that they should put
it on the map
how are you expecting anyone to put
anything on a map if you never put it on
a map if you don't talk about it
if you hide where you from and you
hiding because you want to be cool
i've been repping where i'm from since i
came in this business nothing's changed
i have that [ __ ] tattered i have kosovo
on my belly i have it on my hand you
have to see i can't hide it
you understand they don't rep it and now
they don't have us on the map
and it's because you never wrapped it
and i'm not saying do a leap because
duolippa's been wrapping it and she's
slowly she's from london as well
but like a lot of the other girls they
don't wrap that [ __ ] so i i'm a little
so as a kid obviously i remember
just on the news the kosovo conflict
that was going on when clinton was
president yeah
um i'm not educated so you could educate
me
albania kosovo is is coast like like
kind of
a man kosovo is is we're basically
brother and sister you know what i'm
saying
okay same thing yes i'm just trying to
you know it's the same thing basically
but kosovo is his own country but serbia
and kosovo
have gone into it because of land and
and we got our independence finally but
they still
are not acknowledging us as a country on
on the google maps and putting us
they're putting us as a number
wow you understand that's a problem
because we did
get our independence we are a country a
kosovo is our country
the other thing that pisses me off is
the fact that you know
we shared the flag with albania we
shared the same flag and now we have our
blue flag which is like a blue and
yellow flag
and i don't really respect that because
i i because my people
died for that flag and now you've given
us independence but a new flag it's like
it's not it's like you know what i mean
it's like putting a band-aid over
a cut you know i'm saying but you know i
want us to be respected as a country and
i want us to be
put on the map nothing hurts me more in
my heart it's like every time i land in
kosovo i feel like i'm getting stabbed
in the throat every time my iphone says
welcome to serbia
wow because my my i have families that
died they died you know what i'm saying
sorry about that no it's all good man i
mean i do feel like i had i have
families that died
for this country to be acknowledged i
have families
family members and my people died i've
my people have been raped my people have
been slaughtered and they've been
through a lot
for this country and now you're not
putting us on a map what type of
[ __ ] is that you know what i mean
we've been through it all and we deserve
to be respected and acknowledged as a
country i think it's important to
educate people on that because you know
we just had somebody uh
my boy armen from armenia was kind of
educating me on
uh you know how a lot of people don't
acknowledge the armenian genocide
yeah and a lot of people just don't know
you know and i think that with the
kosovo thing like for me i just kind of
have like i guess a generic
remembrance of being a kid and seeing
the news seeing that there was a
conflict there but i don't necessarily
know
i i don't really know what happened
outside of their you know just seeing
clinton
i think what did u.s aid kosovo
yeah yeah um yeah man i'm
we're going to talk about that when the
camera's okay okay fair enough yeah
we'll talk about that i mean i just
think you know at the end of the day
like
no no no i get now what you said
i just don't want to get too deep into
it because we'll be in a rabbit hole
father but what i'm saying to you is
you know every day i fight for my music
but at the same time i don't want to
forget my roots and where i'm from
you know even though my my people at
times could be super toxic
on me because that one day i don't rep
or say i'm from kosovo they just come
down on me so much any mistake i make
they come down on me and
it's because you know sometimes your
people are harder on you than
than everyone else everyone else you
know what i'm saying so
um but i've been prepping
and you you're proof of that saying yo i
always knew you were all being
because i've been saying this since the
beginning of my career you know
and um
yeah i'm changing i'm changing that and
i just think you know what man
i love my country because they keep me
alive you know once america is over with
gashy and they move on to the next act
my country is going to keep me alive
forever and that's what keeps drake
popping because canada loves him
and that's what keeps rihanna popping
because she her country loves her
that's what keeps kendrick popping
because la loves him right you know what
i'm saying
once you have your hometown you could
get the whole world and you will always
be relevant you always make money
because people know you have roots to
some place
when you come and you don't have love
from your own country and you think you
get popping in a different city you'll
get pop in
five [ __ ] minutes and be out and then
you're done you're done i love my people
i rep for my people you know what i'm
saying these pop artists
this is why i rep i love jim belushi and
this is why my third album is so about
him
it's about me going fully hollywood it's
about me going fully pop
because he's the only male albanian to
ever be allowed in hollywood
do you know how difficult it is to be
accepted in hollywood you don't
understand especially in the 80s
except yeah right i'm about to be
accepted in hollywood
for the first time with this 1984 album
and in my third one i'm from
i'm fully gonna be hollywood
fully be celebrity right you know you
know what i'm saying
so you said like the target walmart
reference exactly that might be the last
yeah this might be the last thing so
it's a big deal when you have eight
girls right now
on the billboard charts that are
albanian that are
killing it and i'm the only
male albanian to ever do it in america
ever they will ever
you don't know when next time you'll see
me
i'm a total different beast you will
never
you will never but this might be the
last time you
ever see anything like this in your
entire life that's how crazy it is for
my country
super super super super solid
super super duper
solid people you can't even wear a pink
shirt
around someone super
aggressive manly
man to see me do pop music and dance the
way i do
to be acknowledging elle and john and be
saying
dressing up with my pants the way they
are and doing this like
such a culture shock what is this kid
doing
why is he talking to the kids from my
country like it's over it's a right to
accept
everyone for who they are to write to do
this it's a right to
not being a gangster throwing up gang
signs shooting people i'm on new york
times not because i caught bodies
because of my music
it's a total different thing that my
country's never seen before
the kids are looking at me like what the
hell i don't have to kill someone to be
famous
like i'm totally going in a different
direction and a lot of people
are trying to close doors on me that are
in the hollywood but they can't
because i'm fully in now i'm officially
in now you can't stop it anymore
and i earned my way in i wrote every
single song with my bare hands you can't
stop it
i made it this is why it's a big deal
for my country this is why it's a big
deal for a male
like me to be in there because i'm
teaching all the kids
rather they're gay rather they're
they're into like
pop music rather they're actually into
the color pink and are
probably straight that maybe they're
into the things that they're not
supposed to be into
i'm i'm trying to teach them that
they're it's okay it's okay to like
it's okay to be yourself to be yourself
it's okay to like the things you like
it's okay
and that is what i'm doing and i think
it's the biggest moment for my country
well
i guess we'll end it on that man um 1984
1984. go get it go get it and uh
buy some merch yeah buy merch at
gastryworld.com
uh support man you know i mean and uh um
i i always donate to brothers global
citizen or
a different foundation i'm always i'm
always donating again
um and that that third album is already
i'm assuming it's already in the works
yeah i'm ready yeah so um
are you gonna please watch my
documentary called now you know
it's on youtube everyone should give it
a watch yes yes and uh bootleg thank you
so much you've always showed me love i
appreciate you good man
and uh just feels good
feels good to be here feels good to be
alive it feels good
yeah this is why i didn't want to do
zoom man because we this is the
conversation we gotta have
we couldn't have this conversation i
mean i got i got kova test we have proof
i got covetousness i believe you i'm
just saying like this is why i was like
dude i know
i know that me and him have legendary
like there's a legendary conversation to
be had we can't do that over the goddamn
webcam read that read that though no i
see you ladies and gentlemen he is
negative negative
did the covet test before i got here i
was very i didn't want to i know you
have a family
yeah no i didn't want to bring that to
your family i wanted to do it i
appreciate it i'm trying to take care of
everybody but yeah
negative on covid i i've been having a
lot
of fun since my album came out i don't
want to bring that here
but albums out documentaries out a lot
of things is on the works
and i'm just so thankful to even be here
to even have you
interview me or and i mean i thank you
for coming man because i feel like you
know
you're like i said man your energy is
incredible your story is incredible and
as as much i'm glad you did the
documentary thank you
because i feel like that's something
that people need to see and it's
you know i think that you have a very
inspirational story and anytime
you know i can help help give you a
platform to tell it or you know be a
part of you are right now
right now you know what i'm saying right
now what's up this is gashi
and uh shout out to bootleg kev thank
you so much for having me
and uh i'll see you in the future shout
out joey franchise too
shout out joey franchise love you